ce que dit aujourd'hui on se retrouve
pour la troisième et probablement
dernière fois sur un guerrier où il faut
qu'on finisse premier on a un rêve une
quête légendaire entamé une épopée
périlleuse c'est parti on va s'appeler
france parce qu'on fait honneur à la
patrie
[ __ ] j'suis trop chaud trop chaud je
vais tout bouffer je vous jure ça va
faire mal et regardez là lui se croit
malin me suivent la et baba le cop
hollande le camp ça fait très plaisir
d'être de retour sur hyères poyaud vous
savez pourquoi je sois fier premier à
mais il nous faut que quelqu'un à jeudi
nous alors il ya une touche en fait c w
ça permet de dissocier un mec
voilà comme ça allik au nom au dos mais
c'est pas grave il ya eu fuite il suit
il ya plein de points là haut up là haut
attendez wall street et wall street et
non non je n'ai fait grossir il est trop
gentil j'ai fait grossir il a rendu ce
que je lui ai donné aux il est trop
mignon bien la tagline vas-y c'était
messi booster mes petits pois soit moi
quoi je suivais comme ça et bien à toi
et fais trop le malin j'ai envie d'y
aller
regardez le j'ai envie d'y aller
regarder lens joue à cache cache quoi
bien aller gros chien voilà voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on fait parce qu'on
s'appelle je baise easy first lol voilà
comme ça c'est bien roggan c'est
aujourd'hui qu'on veut être premier
c'est aujourd'hui que tout se met contre
nous j'aime les mais pourquoi je suis un
être je refais tu as tu manges à foetus
[ __ ] de foire et quand je serai
premier je te mangerais dix fois
des bains cadre du ciel vous avez vu ça
on s'habille tellement bien là il faut
qu'on tue ce valentin 45 en plus on sait
d'où les pourris quand tu mets ton
prénom et un chiffre dans la même dans
le même temps et je vais tous vous
défoncer la maison valentin arrête ton
pseudo est pourri voilà tu es nul à
rennes 1 et georges pas du tout comme
toi non oh merci non il va bouffer mon
boire hier voilà ça t'amuse espèce de
nom mais laura ça m'affecte au poste oui
tu vas me faire ça m'affecte pas du tout
il veut il veut que moi il veut que moi
le mec il a pas de vie phoque
laura innes as il a été de faire manger
par le rail laval pris le gars non les
pédales mais là il ya tous les gros
outch savoir si on en fait pas ça
m'épate à metz comme ça mais qu'est-ce
qui doit se disputer pour boire un à un
à bord des finances d'une gaine data à
l'étagé au lithium
c'est drôle les mecs ce split pour un
gars qui fait franchement ça toi moi
leur taille
ça veut rien dire je vous baise on peut
l'avoir un peu avant on peut l'avoir un
peu la voix ok les gens commencent à
avoir une petite taille adéquate
surtout si on mange bio au abbaoui aulas
est plus qu adéquat à j'ai fait une
erreur mamma mia mamma mia et un truc
vert entre nous et lui
non j'ai envie d'exploser j'ai envie
d'imploser j'ai envie de pippo thé
jouby's nord est va se quitter ce groupe
suzanne oiseaux dit me and i'll try
bouffe moi et je pleure
voilà peut-être qu'ils auront pitié
chaque rêve met du temps à se réaliser
et je te belles gens neymar en russie
une nouvelle partie oh mon dieu regardez
on est déjà 8e alors que ça vient de
commencer
ah oui oui là nous il ya nous ils à nous
il s'est coincé il s'est coincé il est
entre nous deux c'est l'un de nous deux
qu'il bouffe c'est moi ça me fait ça ni
faut arrêter d'aller très vite comme ça
ça dit que c'est un peu du tout oh oui
oh oui
donc on a des origines il ya là bien
dans mes bras je n'abandonnerai jamais
mon rêve
ben déjà six mois ça fait mal c'était un
petit cadeau fidme or die
voilà c'est à dire donne moi un bon fait
ou tumeurs au coeur les yes i watch you
oh oh oh
l'éjaculation non le cal chaud au live
ce qui s'est passé c'était hors du
commun sacre à pékin
jusqu'au from her faut que je performe
non j'suis pas loin d'abandonner le
moral n'est plus là xian a alors haussé
leur apporter un peu de réconfort ça
fait du bien au moral j'ai toujours pas
aux îles ma fille d' il est adorable
prends pas mes points bordel il me
nourris au mercy a donné on va lui
rendre quand même tiens non non et pape
a au nom n'y avait ni tu nous manqueras
[ __ ] wade - les petits elle points qui
s'approche le bes
je pleure ma vie' nul aujourd'hui en ce
28 juin
rien ne va dans ma vie j'ai besoin de
votre énergie telle somme beaucoup et le
junkie d'abba mettez-vous tout sur raga
rios et nourri ces sommes financeront
pas tellement bas est nourrice et moi
habitants de la terre et des mois
l'autre de faire ce france non je suis
sur le chantier en abonnés non tu peux
pas faire ça non mais les terriens j'ai
demandé votre énergie
j'ai pas dans es ce que vous me dit que
t'étais une fille tu le voudrais
pour squeeze tu te plaît aux médailles
voilà voilà
w appuyé sur tout projet et m'a dit je
te laisse en vie attention ils auraient
tous les autres oui merci
[Musique]
allez tiens sacamerd au mercy le mec qui
s'appelait squeeze c'est trop gentil tu
m'a redonné du courage squeeze haut mais
pourquoi il fait genre que ces brosses
et moi moi s'il te plaît ce quoi s'il te
plaît volée ratée cap on peut [ __ ] au
haut on a les capacités mais on les
exploite pas c'est ce que me disaient
mes profs en cinquième tu viens pas d
orlando
allez viens trois morts dont trois comme
l'attendait 3
c'est parfois j'ai composé à rs vient
pas de nos droits mais on n'a pas réussi
je suis de goûter les épais mais les
deux semaines aux applis merci pour
votre aide détériore et c'est quand même
super drôle on peut le dire trois autres
très bien entendu de 3,7 vite et robert
savoir regarder pente et vont bientôt
tout le monde pis
[Musique]